thanks jc all right remember my segment
highlighting local people places and
events that are just so vegas well it's
back today with a special raiders
edition showing you how we're winning at
allegion
you don't get any more vegas than a
nightlife experience inside a stadium so
welcome to the winfield club hunter you
know usually clubs inside arenas or
stadiums or behind the scenes hidden in
the back but this one you get the best
seat in the house right yeah there's no
doubt about that we basically took a win
nightlife venue and put it inside a
legion stadium on the field level spans
the entire north end zone it's got the
full nightlife experience with wind
beverage and food options for all events
inside the stadium okay so then let's
talk about the food options because
obviously you guys have a really nice
setup right here what can we expect yeah
so these are some of the items that we
have this is the tiered shellfish tower
this is something that a table guest can
pre-order prior to booking their tables
along with the charlie's giant pretzel
which is a staple in the wind casino and
then we have some stacks that everybody
can kind of just grab on i love it and
besides the food and the drinks you guys
have dj's in here it's a it's a true
nightlife experience yeah it's a real
nightlife experience two dj booths that
we have artists playing from throughout
the game before the game and after the
game wow how can people actually get
tickets to the winfield club yeah so
anybody that's interested in joining us
here at winfield club can go on
withnightlife.com to either purchase
tickets or inquire about tables and what
can we expect tonight for opening night
this is going to be we've been waiting a
long time for this finally we're very
excited it's going to be a sold-out
house in here and we're super excited
for the raiders to take over okay so
what's your favorite memory so far in
the windshield club um so far there's
been a lot of memories we've had some
good events with guns n roses the gold
cup final we had diplo and major laser
join us during one of those events it's
been it's been a really good time okay
it is just the beginning because now we
can cheers oh yeah the opening night for
the raiders welcome to raider nation
hunter thank you thank you for coming
cheers club cheers to the raiders let's
do it
[Music]
[Music]
the energy okay
it was empty when i went there for that
segment but the energy was already there
feel that you can feel it
walk through the doors what was that
thing they put that can down and they
lift it up was that nachos
you'll have to get your ticket to win
field club to go find out okay when are
we going
as soon as possible it was so dope in
there that's awesome i'm jealous leave
it to the wind to provide the vibes of
course right yeah i love the uh how you
set up too winning winning winning
winning